in light of recent events a FoxNews
judge has called president Donald Trump
an unindicted co-conspirator and you
might be shocked to hear that it wasn't
that wacky FoxNews judge Jeanine Pirro
who we've talked about before it was the
slightly less wacky Fox News Judge
Andrew Napolitano it's fascinating stuff
in total we're going to look at a clip
which will include sort of some of the
lead-up to this and then the key moment
of this segment
obviously with Fox News's Shepard Smith
which is basically the only place on Fox
News where logic and reason seem to
exist with the occasional Chris Wallace
one time Neil Cavuto here is Judge
Andrew Napolitano speaking to Shep Smith
on Fox News explaining that the
President of the United States is an
unindicted co-conspirator take a look
Fox News senior judicial analyst Judge
Andrew Napolitano was here hello judge
hey chef earlier today you said to Bill
Hemmer he's going to talk to him one way
or another and by that I mean the
president is going to talk to Bob Muller
one way or the other you're like look
they can sit down one-on-one with a
lawyer whispering in in the in the
president's ear right or a grand jury
can subpoena where think that a grand
jury subpoena is a real thing that might
come for president Trump yes I do
I think that Bob Muller knows that he
needs to lock the president in to a
version of events before he takes the
next step whatever the next step is
whether it's indictment or whether it's
a referral for you really think you
really think mother might indict the
president well last week in a federal
district court here in New York City a
federal judge at the end of Michael
Cohen sentencing said the president
orchestrated and paid for this crime the
crime to which she was referring to one
of the nine to which Michael Cohen had
pleaded guilty so you're saying the
president's an unindicted co-conspirator
yes I'm also saying that there's ample
evidence this doesn't require too much
analysis to indict the president the
question is they want to do it right
totally clears the president is that the
phrase Trump came up with a few days ago
Judge Andrew Napolitano Singh molar
wants to speak to Trump we
ultimately get his way and speak to
Trump Trump is an unindicted
co-conspirator there is quote ample
evidence to indict the president this is
from a Fox News judge on Fox News that
dirty liberal pinko commie ret wait a
second right it's Fox News Fox News now
according to the right
spreading fake news about Donald Trump
now in seriousness Pat is Judge Andrew
Napolitano the pinnacle of legal
analysis
no in fact Napolitano was previously
reportedly suspended by Fox News for
falsely stating that President Obama had
wiretapped
not George W Bush Donald Trump which was
a widely debunked false statement made
by Donald Trump at some point but isn't
it still fascinating Pat that this is
what's being said at least in this tiny
little one corner of Fox News because it
happens to coincide with what others
have been saying as well yes it is
fascinating because Andrew Napolitano
though he's not the most credible he is
still the Fox News judge and Trump's has
spoken highly of him in the past
actually considered him for his cabinet
maybe even the Supreme Court so I think
this is pretty telling so one other
person who happens to have the exact
same opinion as Fox News Judge Andrew
Napolitano on this issue is Democratic
congressman ted Lieu check out what ted
Lieu had to say not long ago michael
cohen specifically says that donald
trump directed him to make these
campaign finance payments that means we
have a person sitting in the White House
right now who is essentially an
unindicted co-conspirator and we have a
lot more we're gonna find out about
possibly what Donald Trump knew and what
he did when Michael Cohen
testifies more after his prison time is
over according to his lawyer yeah so
this is just the reality that we have to
contend with right now and I think that
this is actually a good moment to show
you how far we've come
I talked recently yesterday about how
crazy the last year has been here's
another fact to think about under that
context not that long ago
Donald Trump was insisting that he's not
personally under investigation
how laughable is that at this point I
got an email this morning about if Trump
committed crimes to become president
shouldn't everything he did as president
be canceled out if indeed that's the
determination now that's never going to
happen in reality obviously I wouldn't
even suggest that in any kind of serious
manner but it reminded me of that thing
that Trump has said before about
undocumented immigrants if you came here
illegally you've got to go back that's
sort of something that at least should
conceivably apply to presidents as well
even though it's not going to but the
point is it's not looking good here
we'll see what the next week brings the
28:18 season finale is shaping up to be
a huge bombshell and you have now
Democrats and even some Republicans who
are saying Trump has committed felonies
here he just hasn't been indicted for
them absolutely stunning